the PERT election-year offered up a
rather conclusive ending to James to
Monaco's dystopian film trilogy but he
still isn't done scaring the pants off
anyone with a finger on the political
pulse just yet for its fourth outing the
purge series is heading back in time to
the very first purchase staged by the
new founding fathers of America to show
how such a brutal holiday became a part
of society to begin with the first purge
will arrive in theaters on Independence
Day 2018 and the film is expected to be
very direct of its real-life
socio-political parallels while still
offering a bloody good time of the
theatre here's what you need to know
about the first purge before heading out
for the next round of mayhem contained
mayhem whereas the original purge
trilogy took place long after the annual
night of terror overtook the entire
United States
the first purge will focus solely on
Star Island in New York that setting has
been chosen to serve as a host of the
inaugural evening of violence at a time
when people are still unprepared for the
levels of depravity it will unleash from
the trailers it is clear that certain
members of the neighborhood will
standard vocal resistance to the concept
of the purge however as we already know
from the first three films their efforts
will ultimately fail to stop the spread
of violence and in fact the efforts of
the marginalised to demand justice might
just be part of the reason the tradition
takes hold of the rest of the nation in
the first place your government thanks
you for your participation spectator
sports in the film we'll meet the woman
who creates the experimental night of
lawlessness and she seems to think a
terrible test is going to satisfy the
bloodlust of everybody in America if we
want to save our country we must release
all our anger in one night however many
of this purchase participants will have
to be bribed into sticking around which
means most of them are from a very
vulnerable sector of society as demonaco
told vulture what they do is start
promising very decent sums of money for
their very poor people in the
neighbourhood it becomes a monetization
of murder and violence incentivizing
killing and keeping people around for
them to be victims the trailer also
hints at military members will be hired
to enter the experiments and slaughter
people to help amplify the entertainment
for audiences tuning in so there might
not be enough people itching to maim
each other before the big guns start
stepping in real life parallels in 2016
election year there was some
unintentional albeit eerie overlaps
current events including the
similarities between Donald Trump's make
America great again campaign slogan and
the film's own keep America great
tagline with the first purge however the
parallels are no longer accidental the
first poster made that clear from the
start
depicting a simple red ball cap bearing
the film's title and a striking
resemblance to Trump the signature hurts
the movie is also expected to use
similar language and cultural anxieties
as those related to the current
administration including having one of
the key motives of the nffa being a
dying economy sound familiar
surprising inspiration Frank willows Leo
Barnes also known as the sergeant and
Edwin Hodges Donte Bishop may have
arrived as hesitant heroes over the
course of the first three purge films
birth this time around the Monaco isn't
pulling any punches when it comes to
who's leading the good guys
Ilan Noelle's character William is shown
in the trailer gathering the
neighborhood troops to rebel against the
purge and he seems to have some
well-developed fighting skills according
to the Monaco the character is an
antihero who was originally inspired by
Clint Eastwood's role in Unforgiven will
money money was a former assassin who
was recruited to serve up some vigilante
justice and proved to be effective at
taking lives so we should expect some
pretty badass fight scenes ahead fresh
blood demonaco wrote and directed all
three of the original purge films but
this time he's taking a backseat to
allow a new director to guide the
franchise the script is still his
creation but the first purchase being
held by relative newcomer Jared McMurray
whose son dance debut burning sands
caught the Monaco's eye it was one of
MacMurray's for your life experiences
that helped him get the gig though as
demonaco told vulture he lived through
Hurricane Katrina and Katrina was one of
the early influences on the purge itself
when I saw the treatment of the people
in the Ninth Ward by the government so
we met with Gerard it was just the
perfect fit even before hiring McMurray
demonaco knew he wanted to feature a
predominantly black cast in the film as
has been important to him since the
second instalment to put people of color
at the center of his films as he
explained we always talk about how the
only way to change the system is to make
successful things of a black lead or
female lead it's the only way to do it
at first we were saying it's not a race
movie it's more about class but
ultimately
races class the subject of
socio-economic disparity seems to be
front and center of the newest /
film but for those who won so interested
in the message the film might still be
for you because thrills and chills
there's no doubt that the monaco and the
rest of the first purchased creators
made a movie with a political point even
the inclusion of real-life CNN host
found Jones on the cast makes for a very
meta moment of questioning their tactics
of government however for those who have
tuned out the 24-hour news cycle and
want a plain old popcorn and gore
theatrical experience there's plenty of
that as well as to Monaco promised the
people who want to can see the parallels
to our society and the reflection upon
our government and talk about that after
the movie or they can watch it as just a
real fun kick-ass action horror film so
it sounds like there'll be a little
something scary for everyone when the
first purge lands in theaters this July
4th 2018 thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love today
[Music]